last night we we had a fun show last  night last night we had tim gunn  from the project runway on the program  people liked her  and tim gunn is a fashion expert and  we were talking on the show about a  women's fashion  uh look that i absolutely love and it  was a nice sort of organic moment take a  look  okay this is what i really want to talk  about it's this new phenomenon the  ladies are wearing them  they're driving me crazy jeggings not  just ladies men too  men don't wear jegs oh they're out there  let me tell you  what they are out there could i wear  jeggings what if i wore for a whole show  i wore jeggings one night  what if i did that seriously i have a  motto on this new show if i say i'm  gonna do something  i do it  hey  news from washington  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  yeah the obama administration uh  i'm gonna try some jokes recently set  aside over 120 million acres of what  you